[Music]
what were you smoking let's start there
Holley weed was a plate that I started
spinning two and a half years ago and I
honestly thought like well that's it
it'll spin and I'll never touch it again
now we're getting to kind of go back to
it it's exciting it happened at a time
right after I had the heart attack man
so it's kind of fueled it for me cuz I
was like I used to be like wow it didn't
work I don't want to bother anybody
through this anymore and stuff I'll just
kind of skulk away and after the heart
attack is like but I almost died like
let's do everything and so the idea
doing this show falls squarely in the
crotch of that of doing everything and
it's it's fun it's nerve-wracking and
stuff and I think it's the first step to
a larger TV crew it's definitely got
like a clerks ask vibe to which it's a
lot more weed literally yes it's clerks
in a weed store I liked when I had
written clerks years ago I wrote the
part of Randall to play myself which is
why he has all the best jokes and then
as we got close to production I was like
I'm no actor I can't do this why did I
think I could act which is weird because
I never stopped to say I'm the director
why did I think I could direct and I had
zero experience in both using impostor
syndrome a little bit always but I have
that my entire life I mean I'm into this
job now next year is gonna be my 25th
year 25 years since clerks and so
quarter of a century and there are days
you absolutely feel like a fraud a
pretender a fake ER and stuff like that
but you know the good news is it's a
make pretend business so being a fraud a
faker make the time actually kind of
works it's on game the show you're right
that there's a pilot but then there was
immediately like that crowdfunding push
for more episodes have you had to change
up your your smoking habits you know
post-surgery no oh post-surgery no after
the heart attack
there was a one day where I didn't smoke
weed I baked it like I didn't smoke a
joint cuz I was like oh man like maybe
that had something to do with it but I
talked to my doctor my GP like a week
after the heart attack and I was like I
hate asking this question but like you
know I smoked a lot of weed that day and
then I had that heart attack do you
think those two things are tied together
and she was like no in fact I didn't you
say that you were calm the whole time
and I was like yeah they kept talking
about the paramedics like you're really
calm man that's gonna get you through
this and stuff I was like yeah what
super come she's like it's probably
because you were so high she's
that joint you smoke probably saved your
life I was like what do you mean she's
like people find out they're having a
heart attack and they're told that it
compounds the heart attack like suddenly
you're like I'm gonna die and they get
real nervous and it makes even worse and
she was like you were blaze so you were
like I'm dying okay like I just took it
in stride and I was like what next so
she was like the fact that you were calm
Factory you smoke weed probably saved
your life can I put that on t-shirts do
whatever you want yeah that's pretty
incredible we'd say that we'd saved it
that's that's true that is literally
your first kids yes so tell your parents
that meantime they're like you can't
smoke weed but like it saved that fat
guy from clark's his life and now he's
not so fat anymore I dropped a bunch of
weight because of it you look incredible
thank I don't know about that but thank
you I did drop a bunch of weight I went
vegan that was that was the big
difference that was the big life change
a lot of people like oh man like now is
your work gonna be different or I guess
they mean better and I'm like now cuz
like I never held anything back in the
job right like if you seem tough clearly
there's a guy who's not like I don't
know if I should tell the story like I
have no no bar whatsoever so I just make
whatever I want but it was on the
personal side where the changes came
like you know I just assumed I'd be fat
my whole life and stuff and I'd never
see my high school weight again or any
of those things when I'm 47 years old
that was all in my rearview but after
the heart attack suddenly I was like
alright well I never want to be back in
that room again with somebody going up
my groin to get to my heart through my
femoral artery and telling me that like
there's a 20% chance that I'll live and
an 80% chance I'll die I was like I
never want to be back in this room how
do I get away from that and the
nutritionist at the hospital is like
you'd go vegan you can cut out all the
animal products we won't have any of
that cholesterol you won't have an
occluded el-ad a Widowmaker and stuff
and so I was like alright you know I ate
anything I wanted my whole life you try
one year just going flat out vegan and
so far like so good honestly like I'm
not a I got no skin in the game so I'm
not like selling it like that but I
don't get the meat sweats anymore I
don't know if you've ever had that but
you ever eat so much where you're like
oh you just feel like I'm an Aussie ate
it from food I have gone to veggie grill
and packed packed like nachos and a
beyond burger and stuff like that and
even a Wonderbra never felt sick full
sated but never like oh I've eaten too
much and back in the day
too much you'd be like I need hair of
the dog so I eat more and get even
sicker now I don't do that you can eat
as much you want you never really get
sick when it's plant-based there's just
a little information for those wondering
yeah go vegan smoke a lot of weed I got
all the green do you know what time the
Degrassi Hall age panel is no I don't
but I you know that's because I went to
my own personal Degrassi panel a few
weeks ago and I'm the Drake video shoot
that was nuts
yeah can we talk about that like how did
that come together I mean I don't know
how it came together for them I guess
like he was always thinking about one
day I want to do at a grassy video and
that's the one they picked and stuff so
I only got involved cuz they wrote to us
and say hey you want to be you want to
be in the video Jay and I had done bit
parts over a few episodes in Degrassi
like season four I think it was in
Degrassi next generation so we yeah
honestly for my money yes well I I go
three tubes I love the Mannie and Craig
romance that really captured my
imagination I was younger so I you know
a big fan of that world always have been
and because of that when they were
making the video he's like why don't you
guys come up which is really nice to be
involved in a class reunion that we
weren't technically a part of the
classic all those kids literally went to
school to a fake school and real school
together and so that we got to carpetbag
and come along for the ride was really
nice it was sweet for Degrassi fan
because you just sitting there watching
all these kids realizing like they are
each other's friends this is their
childhood they all grew up together on
the show so this weird fake reunion in
the middle of this music video is like
an actual school reunion that's going on
for these kids it was it was very nice
to be around therefore I like to think
of the whole thing as canon I agree
completely but that to me as Degrassi
family Jimmy got out of the chair years
later absolutely and also Rick survived
and then was killed later in the
hallways but I as a guy who's a big fan
of the show alright when they were
shooting it I turned to the director
Karina at one point I was like this is
like the most expensive and edgiest
episode of Degrassi that ever happened
it really goes there did that one
certainly went there it really is crazy
though because when when
Drake came around I was like that is
Aubrey Graham me too me too
it was it's weird well it was weird to
go to the shoot
last time I hung out with him were work
to them he was operating yeah and then
this time he's got like a secret
identity he's got a different name
altogether so I just talked right to him
yeah you know I didn't want to be like
hey Aubrey and haven't be like it's
Drake now and it want to be like hey
Drake and have to be like dude it's all
free so I just like how are you yeah I
looked right at him you you it's all
comic-con you're like as you sit there
trying to remember I'm like huh what is
his name and then when he leaves you
like Jason Momoa that was it